the best way to come back into the  present moment is the five four three  two one method  you want to start off by looking around  wherever you are  and noticing the five things you can see  it could be the windows  the walls the ceilings you then want to  focus on the four things you can touch  it could be something you're wearing and  you really want to feel the texture it  could be what you're sitting on just  noticing it and really grounding  yourself and holding on to that then  it's about three things you can hear it  could be nothing it could be white noise  then the two things you can smell inhale  could be a scent you're wearing it could  be a flower and then finally the one  thing you can taste  when you practice this it brings you  back into the present moment  and helps you  not focus on the anxiety of the  nervousness but on taking action from  exactly where you are